yeah I don't think reparations for  something that happened 150 years ago  for whom none of us currently living or  responsible is a good idea  we've you know tried to deal with our  original sin of slavery by fighting a  civil war about passing landmark civil  rights legislation we've elected an  african-american president I think we're  always a work in progress in this  country but no one currently alive was  responsible for that and I don't think  we should be trying to figure out how to  compensate for it first of all it'd be  pretty hard to figure out who to  compensate we've had waves of immigrants  as well who've come to the country and  experienced dramatic discrimination of  one kind or another so no I don't think  reparations are a good idea